[Music]
welcome back we usually have our morning
cup of joe's segment with sheriff joe
lombardo on wednesdays he's running for
governor so
instead we have mornings with metro and
we're joined by share under sheriff
christopher darcy thanks for joining us
this morning thank you very much i
appreciate the time to be here this
morning good stuff okay so
let's talk about a serious issue in the
valley the number of homicides uh
it's concerning there have been a lot of
high profile cases here in the valley
a lot of them tend to be connected to
domestic violence
what is metro doing to try and bring
that rate of crime down
yeah well as you can see across the
country right we're experiencing a rise
in homicides and and we're not immune to
that here in las vegas we're up about 68
percent
but i'm happy to say that our clearance
rate is over 93 percent
so we're solving the murders that are
occurring a lot of the incidents that we
respond to
we haven't been called to the residents
previously and as you mentioned domestic
violence is obviously a concern right
so we focus on that partnering with safe
nest and with our victim witness
advocate groups within metro police and
we try to get them to help before we
you know we have an incident as i was
going to say the clearance rate is
obviously good that there are
you know suspects are found and charges
are brought but obviously the ideal
thing would be for whether it's metro or
the community organizations to be at the
scene before it gets to that extreme in
that
deadly level sort of on the same note
here a troubling
series of cases involving children who
have been murdered recently
in the valley there have been several
high-profile cases we've been covering
this has to be challenging it's
challenging for us as viewers and the
public to see
what are the challenges from a detective
from an investigative standpoint
to get to some resolution to get to a
suspect and just
to get dig through the details of these
cases many of our
officers have families they have
children right and you tend to
self-associate with something like that
and we've noticed that really i mean
this year alone john we've had
um six uh children killed under the age
of 14 versus the same time last year
where we had zero
and and they're the rather bizarre
incidents where we haven't had contact
beforehand
yeah so that was it challenging and the
case of the the the seven-year-old found
out in mountain springs they were from
california so there wouldn't have been
no connection here to las vegas
presumably beforehand
correct yeah and that was a case where
we didn't have any opportunity
to intercede what are some ways that
people can de-escalate
road rage so it doesn't escalate to that
level
if you're in that situation there's
there's a lot of adrenaline going
how do you how should people try and
down play or downgrade that level of
emotion
the idea really is to take a deep breath
and not get into a conflict
avoid it right stay in your car call the
police keep driving drive away turn off
the street
it's not worth being in a life or death
confrontation over a perceived traffic
slight
where the person who maybe cut you off
or you cut them off
is purely by accident sometimes are you
seeing more
anger on the roads as well as metro
officers seeing more of that on the
street yeah i think it does translate
into
our everyday activities right i mean we
see it with domestic violence call
increases well under sheriff we
appreciate you joining us this morning
if you have a question for metro police
you can submit it on our website of
course eight news now dot com
find out if your question is answered
every wednesday during mornings with
metro